More than 250 million people live in a
country other than the one they were
born in.
In other words,
they're immigrants and if you at this
number,
it doesn't stop growing in the last 50
years.
It just multiplied by three and only
since the year 2000 is the number of
immigrants has increased by 80 million.
That's 18 million more people who've
left their country in search of a better
life.
We are the dreamers of USA and as you
can imagine,
most of the world's immigrants,
more than 65% of settles in the richest
countries such as the United States,
Germany,
Australia,
and Canada.
I do
this precisely at this fact that is
feeding all over the world
controversial,
furious,
and bitter debates on immigration and
the discourse of many populist movement
in recent years in Europe for example,
we've seen a lot of populist and Zena
phobic parties and merging,
which have targeted immigration
directly.
You've certainly heard it all.
What if they steal our jobs,
put us in danger,
destroy on national identity,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
That's perhaps the most outstanding case
of all of this is Donald Trump.
He's made it very clear,
but he is a president who really doesn't
like immigration except you know,
under really certain circumstances,
trump balked at an immigration deal that
would include protections for people
from Haiti and some nations in Africa.
Demand to know why he should accept
immigrants from quote whole countries
rather than from places like
Norway.
Why on earth would trump think that
Norwegians once it emigrate on master
the United States when they are already
rich Americans?
In fact,
more people are moving from the u s to
Norway and the other way around.
But let us not straight too far from
today's topic because what we're really
looking at today is whether immigration
is actually a danger.
Is it a burden on society?
We want to look at whether the United
States is losing economic and momentum
because of all the immigrants that are
coming into the country.
We want to look at whether the US should
stop the arrival of more foreigners.
So that's,
that's in,
okay.
Now,
if there is one thing that we can all
agree on,
it's that we live in an increasingly
interconnected world that is a world
where it's becoming easier,
faster and cheaper to go from one place
to another.
And there's also
a world where it's easier to connect
with our loved ones where they are.
And as you can imagine,
all of these things make the decision to
pack up and move to another country
much,
much easier.
That's why if there were 90 million
immigrants around the world in the
sixties today,
there are more than 250 million.
And you know what?
We can only expect this number to grow
strongly in the upcoming years first.
It's because it's becoming easier to
move into seconds because of the huge
demographic growth that many poor
countries are experiencing.
So Devi,
you are,
the real question that we want to get
back to is,
is there a reason to worry?
Well,
listen up.
Yeah,
a lucky break.
Whenever
rich countries talk about immigration,
it sounds like that debating whether or
not to engage in some sort of charity
and then you know what's,
nothing could actually be further from
the truth.
Hair,
immigration favors economic growth among
other things because most immigrants are
adults of working age four.
It's been calculated that since the year
2000 immigrants who have been
responsible for 40 to 80% of their main
recipients,
country's workforce growth.
So let's be honest,
without them,
these countries,
that'd be far less wealthy.
Bye.
Yes,
I know this is all very abstract.
If you want to see exactly how this
happens in one of the countries where
immigration has caused a lot of
controversy.
Well,
let's have a look at the United Kingdom
recent years,
while some political groups warns about
the enormous threats that immigration
and including immigrants coming from
other European countries posed for
British jobs,
identity and his way of life.
The truth is that the economy has placed
very,
very different numbers on the team.
Never before in history of so many
people being employed in the United
Kingdom as there are today,
neither in absolute or relative terms
I did,
and it
doesn't even matter if we exclude
immigrants.
Yeah.
Never before as the British population
had as many job opportunities as they do
right now,
and not only that,
it's according to studies from several
British universities,
all these immigrants pay more taxes than
they get in benefits from the state.
And if that weren't enough,
the UK is managing to attract more
university immigrants than any other
European country.
In other words,
the effect of this immigration is very,
very positive for the British,
and it's also helping turn the United
Kingdom into a technological powerhouse.
Not Bad.
Right.
Well,
you know what,
despite trump's fiery speeches,
but the truth is there's,
on the other side of the ponds,
things aren't really any,
listen to this.
I remember
the North American dream
okay.
With just over 44 million people,
which is more or less the population of
Spain.
The United States is in absolute terms.
The country with the most immigrants in
the world.
However,
wait just a moment because in relative
terms,
things are rather difference.
These 44 million people represents just
under 14% of the entire population.
To give you a better idea here,
in countries like Australia or New
Zealand for example,
the percentage is almost twice as high.
Now here is a big question for you and
please don't cheat in Google.
That's what impact do you think
immigration has had on the United
States?
Well,
dear viewer listener,
despite representing just under 14% of
the population,
immigrants are responsible for almost
25% of all businesses that have you been
in the United States.
They're also responsible for more than
30% of the companies in which venture
capital funds invest as almost half of
all silicon valley high tech startups
are started by immigrants and that's
normal here.
According to a study from the Center for
American entrepreneurship,
43% of the 500 largest companies in the
United States were founded either by
immigrants or the children of
immigrants.
Three weeks ago we bought another toward
the new low price custom line.
Victoria,
that's 216 companies whose revenues
surpass it.
$5 trillion every year and employee
almost 13 million people all around the
world.
Okay.
We're talking about nearly half of the
great us economic powerhouse from Henry,
forced to Elon Musk and many of the
great figures and iconic characters over
the United States.
They weren't even born in that country.
No.
Well,
just a,
because I bet something you are probably
thinking right now.
Well,
okay Simon,
but those are only a few immigrants,
the most educated ones.
What about all of the rest,
Simon?
Okay,
well the truth is the numbers,
they don't very much here either.
That entrepreneurship and employment
rates,
they're also really high and by the way,
they also provide several other
benefits.
For example,
in a country that at the moment has
pretty much full employment.
New immigrants reinforce the U S is
competitiveness,
encourage the rest of the American
population to do more as an alpha.
Many businesses that would have
otherwise not existed to be creative.
In summary,
integralist reduce the populations
average age.
They have more children or more educated
and is more enterprising.
They far more patterns as well.
The list goes on,
and if you think about it for a second,
it does make a lot of sense on the one
am's.
These people arrived,
you achieve a better future.
So they're willing to take risks and
work really hard.
No.
On the other hands,
they've had different experiences and
it's education and they can take
advantage of this in order to progress
thing.
For example,
if Italian pizzas aren't Mexican tacos
that flood for us today as well as the
rest of the wells.
Well,
despite these arguments and the facts
that never before have so many Americans
had jobs as politicians like Donald
Trump still don't like immigration.
But you know what?
This isn't the first time that the u s
political leaders have spoken out
against immigration.
It has become the issue and the
governor's right.
Pete Wilson,
a one 87 supporter,
is pinning his reelection hopes on Eddie
immigrants.
The precedents.
This is by no means that the United
States,
the country of immigrants,
has had political campaigns against
them.
You see in the middle of the 19th
century,
the political movement,
no and nothing opposed immigration,
particularly from the Irish and soon
after if they focused on the Chinese.
Yep.
You heard that,
right?
They,
we're focusing on the Chinese.
During the second half of the 19th
century,
many of Chinese came to the United
States and that triggered a rather
hostile,
popular reaction.
Seattle to Los Angeles from Wyoming to
the small towns of California.
Immigrants from China were forced out of
business,
run out of town,
beaten,
tortured,
lynched,
and massacred usually with little hope
of help from the law.
Immigration work from the library of
Congress,
all this because at that time Americans
saw the Chinese as the competition ends
in 1982 the federal congress itself a
preview to the law of exclusion of the
Chinese,
which not only suspended the arrival of
new Chinese immigrants,
but also it made the lives of those who
were already in the u s Rafa complicated
and bottles and home.
In 1924 after around 30 million people
who have crossed the Atlantic Ocean to
reach the u s Washington established a
quote,
a policy that greatly reduced the number
of immigrants that could arrive and they
also vetoed immigrants from southern
Europe such as Spain and Italy as well
as Eastern Europe,
Asia,
and Africa.
So basically the few who it ends or they
have to be Anglo saxons.
Hello,
more
recently in 1994 the then governor of
California,
Pete Wilson,
blamed Hispanic immigrants for the
state's poor economic situation.
And do you want to know what he did?
Well,
he launched a huge political campaign
against immigration and pushed the so
called a proposition one eight seven a
law that prevented access to social,
educational and even health services for
all illegal immigrants.
And yes,
this included children.
It was so aggressive that just a year
later the supreme court declared it
unconstitutional.
We are going to think back California
working tax paying families of this
state.
Well.
The fact is that despite all these
campaigns against immigration,
existing research shows that states and
counties that historically had more
immigration now have a higher income,
less poverty,
less unemployment and better educational
results does that with all this data in
mind,
it might be good for both the White
House and the capitol.
It's a focus less on how to deport
people,
funds more on how to use strength and
access and Tracy to prove once and for
all,
hey,
migrator reform that facilitates the
orderly arrival of more people,
more workers,
more entrepreneurs and more researches.
All of this would great and the age,
the North American economy,
by the way,
in a future video,
which we'll try to make available very
soon for our patrion page and later here
on this channel,
we're going to discuss the great myths
that exist about immigration,
but now,
well it's your turn.
Do you think your country should reduce
the entry of immigrants or should they
increase it?
Well,
leave your answer in the comments below
as well as in this a vacancy.
I really hope you enjoyed this video.
Please do hit that like of us,
and if he did,
and don't forget to subscribe to our
channel for brand new videos that don't
forget to check out our friends at the
reconsidered media podcasts.
They provided the vocals in this episode
that were not mine,
and this is always thank you for
watching.
It has become the issue and the
governor's race,
he dwells in a one 87 supporters is
pending his reelection hopes on anti
immigrant sentiment.